as far as the state of Alabama is
concerned the execution was a success
Smith was pronounced deceased by
physicians at
825 58-year-old Kenneth Smith convicted
for his role in a 1988 murder For Hire
was forced to breathe nitrogen gas a
form of Suffocation while strapped to a
gurnie journalists were allowed to watch
he appeared conscious for several
minutes into the execution
for about 2 minutes following that
Kenneth Smith Shook and rides uh for
about 2 minutes on a gurnie that was
followed by several minutes of deep
breaths Smith's lawyers say the use of
nitrogen gas violated the US
Constitution's ban on cruel and unusual
punishment a view backed by
demonstrators who opposed the death
penalty United Nations experts warned it
could be painful and would likely
violate prohibitions on torture but the
US Supreme Court denied Smith's appeal
Jeff Hood his spiritual adviser was with
him at the end over and over again we
were said that this was going to be the
most Humane execution that Humanity has
ever ever
experienced there is no doubt that even
the most hopeful of
persons could not look at what we saw
tonight and see any sort of humanity
this was the second attempt to execute
Smith in 2022 prison officials spent
hours trying to give him a lethal
injection but never hit a vein going
forward Alabama as well as two other
states that still allow capital
punishment plan to use nitrogen to
inflict the ultimate punishment Kristen
salumi Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer